[Musique]
retour sur la manifestation parisienne
d'hier contre le front national
arlette laguiller dans le cortège a
appelé à voter blanc ou nul au second
tour de l'élection dès dimanche dernier
elle avait précisé qu'elle n'appellera
pas à voter pour le président sortant
helen hughes une foule compacte et
unanime contre l'extrême droite mais au
milieu du cortège un groupe se distingue
sur les moyens de lui faire barrage ces
luttes ouvrières et sa stratégie du ni
ni ni le pen ni chirac
je n'appelle pas d'abord à voter le pen
sur tout et je demande aux travailleurs
qui l'ont fait au premier tour de ne pas
le faire au deuxième ensuite je
n'appelle pas à voter chirac et je
demande à mes camarades à ceux qui me
font confiance et bien de voter blanc ou
nul dans cette élection
une position que dénonce l'immense
majorité des manifestants même si avant
d'être pour chirac ils sont d'abord
hostile à le pen il n'empêche le 5 mai
il vous trouvera pour le président
sortant
étant donné qu'au maire de paris
c'est le moment de penser à la
démocratie
le 5 mai il faut pas hésiter alors
mettez des gants si vous voulez des
pinces ou ce que vous voulez mais
frotter fait abaisser le plus bas
possible peine toute la gauche plurielle
appelle à en faire de même le 5 mai la
ligue communiste révolutionnaire d'alain
krivine et olivier besancenot ne s'est
pas encore prononcé vote blanc ou votre
chirac une décision sera prise mardi
[Musique]